hello Sean other demons what are you all
doing down here what do you think we're
doing you hemorrhoid we're ending this
charade once and for all these four
humans are the legal property of the bad
place that's where we're taking them and
you if you want them you're gonna have
to go through me that's the idea well
it's a bad idea
Oh Michael when will you I've been going
to the gym a lot fun guard
obviously I'd never do that in the
competition that'll be three duction
I've never mark Felisa Janet Jackson the
South baby 2,000 points
is it just me or is Janet a straight-up
hottie right now how are you this close
to being dragged to hell and still
demons no screw it
what am I waiting for huh I could die in
the next 30 seconds so Michael showed me
a memory of our time in the good place
and you and I were like a thing and not
like a casual hey I found two loose
pills in the bottom of my tote let's pop
em and see what's good kind of thing we
were in love and there was a real
possibility that I'm in love with you
again here on this plane of existence
today now in Canada during this brawl
with demons
[Music]
oh cool when I'm even partway through
the door to the afterlife my powers come
back they do they do thanks for asking
[Music]
we did it oh well no no no of course of
course Janet did it yes but I have the
UH
Thank You Janice
you